[Musique]
je crois que cet endroit à manquer à
beaucoup de monde moi compris pas moi je
vois juste un fond vert 1 vous emballez
pas ça c'est mon vrai studio j'apprécie
énormément puisqu'il y a le poster de
l'épopée temporel on retourne en 2013 si
je reviens ici enfin virtuellement c'est
pour faire une annonce de quelque chose
qui a commencé dans cet appartement est
d'ailleurs j'ai un petit cadeau pour
vous à la fin de la vidéo on fait
plaisir dans cet appartement c'est là où
j'ai tourné mes vidéos les plus
populaires où j'ai écrit mes premiers
courts métrages mais aussi où j'ai écrit
ma première bande dessinée roger c'est
humain est ce que je savais pas en
faisant cette bd c'est que j'allais
faire ensuite plusieurs tonnes et même
un dessin animé la chaîne youtube à 500
mille abonnés c'est énorme merci
beaucoup d'ailleurs beaucoup d'entre
vous ont été déçus que le dessin animé
s'arrête c'était un peu le rendez vous
du mercredi et là je suis obligée de
vous le dire vous vous trompez je suis
heureux de vous annoncer que la saison 2
du dessin animé roger c'est humain est
disponible intégralement et en
exclusivité sur adn attention pas un
épisode par semaine jaurès et le
mercredi tous les épisodes la t 30 6
épisodes de la saison 2 sont disponibles
maintenant à partir d'aujourd'hui c'est
un projet qu'on a mené un petit peu en
secret puisque toute l'équipe travaille
depuis le début d'année pour cette
nouvelle saison est d'ailleurs c'est
simple c'est ma saison préférée trop
bien je vais pisser debout attends je
vais essayer allez vas-y brazos c'est le
bordel
c'est plus trash c'est plus con c'est
plus joli à bord n'importe quoi comme
thématique et j'ai vraiment hâte que
vous découvriez cette saison là et je
vous ai promis un petit cadeau on vous
offre des jours gratuits sur adn vous
cliquez sur le lien dans la description
vous créez un compte en utilisant le
code roger 2 / adn et vous avez accès
pendant cinq jours à tout le catalogue
gratuitement et je vous dis juste
dépêchez-vous puisqu'un nombre limité de
code ça veut dire que vous pouvez voir
one piece naruto brutto mayereau
academia mais aussi des dessins animés
nom japonais comme mouarf ou kid paddle
mais surtout projet c'est humain la
nouvelle saison en exclusivité et je
vais pas vous mentir voir roger entre le
fis et saitama je trouvais un postier
roger poteau avec le filet saitama
pourquoi pas dans le pas possible et
comme une surprise n'arrive jamais seule
j'ai un petit épisode cadeaux juste pour
vous
[Musique]
non allez
souffler la bougie roger on a une
mission pour toi quelque chose à la
hauteur de tes capacités piraté le
pentagone plus périlleux a raté une
guerre beaucoup plus dangereux faire
exploser de météorites diriger vers la
terre faire rentrer le chat dans sa
caisse bande d'incapables mais c'est
moins cher
abadie dont il a réussi alors bon
biloute hulu qui sait que derrière les
barreaux
cet animal est diabolique témoin sortir
s'il vous plaît
vous allez voir la castration est une
impasse au somment doute assez banal et
après je vous assure qu'il sera tout
comme un agneau astree
vétérinaire balle et moi je vais
préparer mais ce client ça me fait trop
de peine regarde sa petite frimousse on
sent qu'il a peur je le vois dans ses
yeux
roger tu peux nous laisser penser
stocker bien sûr
coupez pas méconnaître je serai sage est
soumise et promis aux le poker on a lieu
l'opération
ces connards de merde je serai douga
metellus
alors côté de lui et couilles docteur
avec grand plaisir quel beau mercredi
roger qu'est ce qui vous donne le droit
de couper ou nous les testicules et au
niveau foot roger c'est déjà pas facile
c'est comme ça on n'a pas le choix il
n'y a pas mieux pour calmer les
caractères un peu récalcitrants et ça
marche surtout les animaux en théorie
oui d'accord je reviens tient cadeau
c'est ce que je crois oui dino drôle
d'histoire le sens d'une petite sieste
et je meurs avec cette voie là
surprenant quand même mais surtout je
ressens aucune forme d'agressivité score
final roger tu peux inverse l'opération
s'il te plaît malheureusement les deux
suis moi
c'est quoi dans la boîte
c'est vraiment un super projet on s'est
vraiment éclaté à faire ces 36 épisodes
jusqu'à vraiment de cette nouvelle
saison vous plaira il ya pas mal de
surprises et je pense que la fin va un
petit peu vous chamboulement j'en suis
extrêmement fier voilà une nouvelle
saison de roger c'est humain qui nous a
pris des mois de travail disponible dès
maintenant sur l'adn vous avez cinq
jours gratuits dites moi quel épisode
vous avez préféré je reviens très vite
dans une nouvelle vidéo que je suis en
train de terminer qui arrive bientôt et
je vous dis bon visionnage et benoît
aussi
[Musique]